Es geht um alle möglichen Arten von Gewalt, die uns geschildert wurden. Es gibt in einigen Fällen starke körperliche Gewalt, es gibt psychische Gewalt. Es ist immer wieder die Rede davon gewesen, dass sie vor allem zum Schweigen gedrängt wurden. Immer wieder wurde ihnen klargemacht, dass sie nicht sich an irgendjemanden wenden sollen, der außerhalb dieser Fußballwelt steht. Also bitte nicht zur Polizei gehen, natürlich nicht in Medien darüber reden. Am besten sollten sie, wenn es überhaupt passiert, sich dann innerhalb der Fußballwelt, also vielleicht an den Berater, vielleicht an den Spieler selber wenden und dort Gesprächspartner suchen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer zu Tribünengespräch Nummer 47. Ich freue mich sehr, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt. Wir haben heute ein wichtiges Thema vor uns. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Und ich freue mich sehr, hier zwei Journalistinnen begrüßen zu dürfen, die eine sehr wichtige, wie ich finde, Recherche mit vollbracht haben. Zum einen Gabriela Keller vom Correctiv. Sie heißt auch Edgabriela Keller auf Twitter. Ich kann sehr empfehlen, zu folgen. Da wird auch so einiges noch passieren. Hallo Gabriela, schön, dass du hier bist. Und ebenfalls hier ist Maike Backhaus, Freisportjournalistin, die auch auf Twitter ist, als Ed Maike Backhaus. Also es ist denkbar, einfach ihr zu folgen. Auch das solltet ihr tun. Hallo Maike.
Welche Rolle spielt denn dabei vielleicht? Also wir haben das vorhin schon mal so kurz gestreift, aber ich glaube, das lohnt noch mal einen genaueren Blick diese archaischen, patriarchalischen Strukturen des Fußballs. Also wenn du eben gerade sagst, Maike, man könnte sich ja in Anführungszeichen einfach nur trennen, dann würde ich als Antwort vermuten, naja, da geht es wahrscheinlich um Egos, da geht es sicherlich auch um einen Markenwert, den jeder Spieler selbst hat. Spielt das da auch noch mit rein, eure Erfahrung nach den Gesprächen, die ihr mit betroffenen Frauen hatten, dass es eben auch eine sehr männliche und sehr, ja, umstärke bemühte Außendarstellung ist, die wir da im Fußball haben?
Also das sind auf jeden Fall, geht es da um Werte. Ich hatte jetzt gar nicht den Eindruck, dass es so stark um die Egos geht oder die Egos zu schützen dieser Spieler, sondern diese traditionellen, sehr rückwärtsgewandten Werte von dem, wie Beziehungen zu sein haben. Tatsächlich eher das. Also zum Beispiel sich dann ja auch teilweise wahnsinnig viele Affären herausstellen, die dann aber, also die irgendwie es gegeben haben soll auf Seite des Profifußballers, wo man jetzt sagen würde, ja okay, dann war das einfach keine gute Beziehung. Aber das darf nicht stattfinden, weil halt eben auch inzwischen Profifußballer nicht mehr nur einfach sehr gute Sportler sind, sondern die sind ja seit ein paar Jahren wirklich zu Nationalhelden geworden und die müssen plötzlich für ganz, ganz vieles stehen, was vielleicht dann auch einfach ganz schwer zu erfüllen ist. Auch da gibt es ja einen ganz engen Rahmen von dem, was möglich ist. Und ich glaube, dadurch gibt es so diese Front, die halt diese traditionellen Familienwerte so fordert. Da spielt ja auch das rein, was Gabriela eben ansprach, dass Homosexualität da keine Rolle spielen darf. Das geht ja in alle möglichen Ecken. Und da fängt es dann schon an, dass es wichtig ist, dass diese Werte, weil die ja eben auch vermarktet werden, dass die nicht angegriffen werden dürfen durch irgendwelche Geschichten, die rauskommen. Und dann gibt es die Front, von dem was kommuniziert werden darf. Und dann aber darf dahinter sich ganz vieles abspielen. Man darf nur nicht darüber sprechen und es darf nicht öffentlich bekannt werden.
Das ist schon ein sehr perfides System, in dem ja gleichzeitig diese Verschwiegenheitserklärung, die NDAs eine sehr große Rolle spielen. Und das ist auch so ein bisschen aus den USA übernommen. Also durch den Harvey Weinstein-Fall unter anderem wissen wir, dass das dort eine sehr große Rolle spielt. Jetzt ist aber das Interessante daran, Juristinnen und Juristen sind sich gar nicht so einig, ob das eigentlich auch im Bereich des Privatlebens so gültig wäre. Denn das kommt ursprünglich so aus dem Unternehmensbereich. Geschäftsgeheimnisse dürfen nicht verraten werden, wenn man zu einem anderen Unternehmen geht und so weiter und so fort. Könnt ihr dazu noch ein, zwei Worte sagen? Denn man kann ja nie ausschließen, dass das hier vielleicht auch jemand hört, der selbst davon betroffen ist und dem das vielleicht so noch gar nicht klar war.
Ja, also es ist so, dass Verschwiegenheitsverpflichtungen im Privatleben juristisch stark umstritten sind. Also man kann davon ausgehen, da sind sich alle Juristen einig, dass bei einem Vorwurf von Gewalt oder Machtmissbrauch, Psychoterror, es würde keinen Richter geben, der sagen würde, ich erkläre jetzt in dem Fall, ich bewerte einen NDA für rechtmäßig und die Frau muss sich daran halten. Also da gibt es ja eine klare Güterabwägung. Und wenn es so ist, dass ein starkes wirtschaftliches Ungleichgewicht der Hintergrund ist, dann sagen Juristen, dass ein solcher NDA sehr leicht sitenwidrig und damit rechtswidrig sein kann. Und wenn es so ist, wie im Fall von Kascha Lenhardt, dass ein NDA nur eine Seite zum Schweigen verpflichtet, dann kann er mit Sicherheit rechtswidrig eingestuft werden.
Aber wir sehen, dass die trotzdem wahnsinnig effektiv sind. Und das ist das Perfide daran. Im Fall von Kascha Lenhardt sehen wir auch, sie hat einen wahnsinnigen Druck. Sie hatte eine Geschichte, die sie hätte richtig stellen wollen. Es ging auch darum, dass sie eigentlich Anzeige erstatten wollen wegen diesen offenbaren Angriffen von ihm. Sie hatte aber den Eindruck, dass sie das nicht kann, weil sie dachte, wenn man so einen Vertrag unterschreibt, geht man schon erstmal davon aus, dass das auch bindend ist. Dann müsste man sich erstmal von einem Rechtsanwalt beraten lassen. Diese Beratungen sind ja auch teuer und aufwendig. Und überhaupt erst einmal an den Punkt zu kommen, zu hinterfragen, ob das hinterfragbar ist, soweit kommen viele gar nicht.
Ja, und es ist tatsächlich auch nicht so ganz einfach. Wir haben auch die NDAs angucken lassen von Expertinnen und Experten. Und zu sagen, dieser NDA ist rechtswidrig, das ist nicht so leicht, weil so eine Vertragsprüfung tatsächlich aufwendig ist. Und wenn ein Anwalt das so bewertet, kann er hinterher auch theoretisch in Regress genommen werden, wenn es sich dann doch anders herausstellt. Das ist auch für die Anwälte ein Risiko. Vertragsrecht ist kompliziert. Also die Angst davor ist sicherlich größer als die juristische Wirkung. Weil man kann ja auch fragen, was passiert denn, wenn sie dagegen verstoßen? Also was soll da passieren? Natürlich können sie erst mal wieder zivilrechtlich verklagt werden. Und wenn eine Vertragsstrafe festgelegt ist, dann kann diese Vertragsstrafe natürlich fällig werden. Aber in mehreren NDAs, die wir gesehen haben, sind auch keine Vertragsstrafen vorgesehen. Andererseits sind sie natürlich häufig Teil von Trennungsverträgen, sodass die wirtschaftliche Grundlage der Frau, die Unterhaltszahlungen für die Kinder gekoppelt sind, an die Schweigeklausel. Und dann ist es natürlich schon irgendwie eine schwierige Sache, weil sich die Frage auftut, ob der Mann dann den ganzen Vertrag aufkündigen kann, wenn die andere Seite gegen eine dieser Klauseln theoretisch verstößt. Und wenn auch nicht festgelegt ist, wo diese Frau sich äußern darf, darf sie sich überhaupt in ihrem eigenen privaten Umfeld äußern, darf sie sich vor Behörden äußern, darf sie sich vor Gericht äußern. Also es gibt NDAs, die da ziemlich klar sind und sagen, vor Gericht hat er jetzt keine Gültigkeit, aber das ist längst nicht in allen Fällen der Fall. Du merkst ja jetzt, wie wir uns abmühen, die rechtliche Gültigkeit dieser NDAs einzuschätzen. Und das ist für jemanden, der so etwas unterschrieben hat, natürlich ein sehr großer Unsicherheitsfaktor. Und es ist ja auch so, dass diese NDAs nicht im luftleeren Raum hängen. Das sind alles Fälle, wo Frauen sowieso schon zu spüren bekommen haben, wie groß das Machtgefälle ist, die sowieso schon eingeschüchtert wurden, die sowieso schon etliche juristische Verfahren mit diesen Männern haben, die sowieso schon die Erfahrung gemacht haben, dass sie eben besser nicht versuchen sollen, sich zu versuchen, gegen sowas zu behaupten.
Ich glaube auch, dass genau diese Unklarheit, die auf verschiedenen Ebenen in Bezug auf diese NDAs herrscht, auch ein Grund ist, warum die so gut wirken. Weil eben zum Beispiel auch gerade, wenn die so sehr diffus formuliert sind, dann schließen die ja so alles und nichts ein. Und dann ist es sehr, sehr schwer abzuschätzen, was die Konsequenzen sind, aber auch, was ich überhaupt darf und was ich nicht darf. Den Frauen ist aber bewusst, dass es eben dieses Machtgefälle gibt und es für sie sehr problematisch ist, wenn sie bestimmte Grenzen übertreten. Und viele Juristen, mit denen wir gesprochen haben, fordern ja auch jetzt einfach sozusagen auf einer anderen Ebene in Bezug auf die NDAs, dass da in Deutschland mehr Klarheit rechtlich geschaffen wird. Also weil das halt tatsächlich so ist, dass ja, meistens würden die vor Gericht nicht standhalten, aber man kann schon auch erstmal verklagt werden und dann muss man halt so einen Prozess erstmal führen und dann muss man erstmal die finanziellen Mittel aufbringen. Und da ist ja dann auch immer die Frage, wer hat da den längeren Atem und wer hat da auch vor allem finanziell gesehen, mehr Möglichkeiten so etwas dann durchzuziehen und durchzusetzen. Und ja genau, in den USA wird ja gerade diskutiert, ob die ganz generell verboten werden sollen, die NDAs in Bezug auf private Beziehungen, weil da ja auch angeführt wird, dass das eben ganz stark ein Problem ist bei Missbrauchsfällen und weil da halt eben dieses Muster erkannt wurde, dass das oft dazu führt, dass eben keine Aussagen getroffen werden, dass es zu so einer Art Knebelvertragssituation wird. Und das ist ja ein Missbrauch von einem Vertrag, den man schon auch, finde ich, in Deutschland mal klar regeln könnte. Auch da fehlt ehrlich gesagt gerade die Reaktion. Also genau.
Ja und gleichzeitig das, was ihr gesagt habt, dass so ein NDA nicht im luftleeren Raum hängt. Also zwei Dinge, glaube ich, muss man da noch verdeutlichen. Das eine ist, die Formulierung in so NDAs, die können sehr drastisch sein. Also ich habe schon einige mal im Leben unterzeichnet, den komischsten Umständen. Und da standen zum Teil Vertragsstrafen von 100.000 Euro drin. Und das macht einem selbst ein bisschen Angst. Und auch diese Allgemeingültigkeit generell darf man, man verpflichtet sich gegenüber Dritten usw. Das ist ein sehr starker Rechtstext, der selbst, glaube ich, erfahrenere, also mit dem Recht erfahrenere Menschen einschüchtern wurde. Und das andere aber eben, es ist eben nicht so, dass man sich in einem gütlichen Gespräch am Küchentisch einigt, sich zu trennen und dann ach, übrigens ich habe noch was mitgebracht, ich habe hier noch eine Verschwiegenheitserklärung. Sondern da sind Dinge vorher passiert und es sind an Dinge, sie können an Dinge gekoppelt sein, wie eben zum Beispiel Zahlungen, wie eben zum Beispiel auch Sorgerecht usw. Dinge. Das heißt, wenn man sich eben die Frage stellt, warum unterschreiben denn diese Frauen überhaupt diese NDAs? Ich glaube, da gibt es viel mehr Gründe, als man sich erstmal so ausmalen könnte, warum man das dann tut.
Absolut und viele verbinden ja auch NDAs. Also wenn man mal davon schon gehört hat, klingt das so nach wie, ja, man verkauft halt seine Geschichte oder es ist so Schweigen gegen Geld und als wäre das dann so ein klarer Deal, der auch so freiwillig abläuft. So habe ich das eigentlich in keiner der Fälle wahrgenommen, dass das die Motivation war. Also teilweise sind das dann Abschnitte in einem Trennungsvertrag. Da geht es vielleicht auch teilweise dann darum, dass man auf den ehemaligen Partner zugeht und sagt, hier, ich versichere dir hiermit, dass ich nicht zu den Medien gehe. Eigentlich alle, mit denen ich gesprochen habe, haben auch gesagt, wir hatten nie vor, sozusagen so dreckige Wäsche bei den Medien zu waschen und dachten deswegen, ich kann das unterschreiben. Die haben das gar nicht teilweise so überblickt, in was für eine ganz schreckliche Lage dieser NDA sie dann später bringen würde, weil sie halt nur daran gedacht haben, der andere will sich absichern, nicht in den Medien auf die und die Art vorzukommen. Und wenn man das dann eh nicht vorhat, denkt man vielleicht auch so, okay, ich kann das so machen, weil eben wie gesagt ja auch nicht immer Geld geflossen ist. Und das finde ich auch nochmal wichtig, um zu verstehen und da nicht wieder so einen Vorwurf daraus zu formulieren von so, naja, sie hätte den Vertrag ja nun auch nicht unterschreiben müssen. Und wie jetzt im Fall von Kashalin hat, ist ja auch offenbar da, dass jetzt auch nicht in einem ganz harmonisch freiwilligen Gespräch abgelaufen, sondern da ist ja sehr, sehr starker Druck auf sie ausgeübt worden offenbar.
Und das führt eben so weit, dass im Harvey Weinstein-Fall wurde so ein Fall bekannt, die ich mir deshalb auch gemerkt habe, wo eine Frau, die einen NDA wegen eines Missbrauchsfalls, den er an ihr begangen hat bei ihrer Therapeutin, sich nicht mal getraut hat, vor der Therapeutin darüber zu sprechen. Also so tief, letztlich auch in die Seele, greifen diese NDAs ein, dass man dann nicht mal mehr in diesem geschützten – eigentlich sollte es ein geschützter Ort sein – sich öffnen kann. Jetzt haben wir, glaube ich, noch so einen weiteren Mechanismus, auf den wir kurz eingehen sollten. Denn immer, wenn das Wort Unschuldsvermutung bei Twitter trendet, dann kann man sich sicher sein, irgendein Mann wurde angeschuldigt, etwas getan zu haben und ganz oft hat es dann auch mit Missbrauch zu tun. Und dann kommt immer die Unschuldsvermutung hoch. Und ihr müsst ja auch mit der Unschuldsvermutung arbeiten. Ihr werdet das sehr genau abgewogen haben, was ihr in euren Texten veröffentlichen konntet und was nicht. Was möchtet ihr denn solchen Menschen sagen, die jetzt eben die Anonymität, unter denen die Frauen sich geäußert haben, gegen sie verwenden möchten, indem sie sagen, na ja, wenn die sich jetzt nicht dahinstellt und das jetzt nochmal alles so belegt und es da kein Verfahren gibt, dann müsste man ja die Unschuld vermuten.
Also ich finde, die Unschuldsvermutung ist ein mega hohes Gut und eine total wichtige Grundlage in unserer demokratischen, freiheitlichen Gesellschaft, dass es die gibt. Man muss aber auch sagen, dass bei Fällen von häuslicher Gewalt oder generell Gewalt gegen Frauen – und das haben wir nun auch mehrfach gesehen – das Rechtssystem oftmals zu kurz greift, muss man tatsächlich sagen. Also man kann – das betrifft jetzt auch nicht nur Fußballerfrauen – das betrifft generell Frauen von häuslicher Gewalt. Da gibt es ganz viele Rechtsexpertinnen und Rechtsexpertinnen, die sagen, dass der rechtliche Schutz für die Opfer eigentlich bei Weitem nicht weit genug geht. Und ganz oft hat man eben so eine Situation von Aussage gegen Aussage. Und man muss ja auch sagen, dass es für uns Medien gilt, gelten die Regeln der zulässigen Verdachtsberichterstattung. Daran haben wir uns gehalten und das haben wir wirklich ziemlich genau abgezirkelt, dass wir – Maike hat das vorhin schon erklärt – wir haben in keinem Fall einfach uns irgendwas erzählen lassen und das dann brav aufgeschrieben von anonymen Quellen, sondern wir haben wirklich sehr viele Belege dafür. Wir haben Dokumente, Fotos, Gerichtsdokumente, Textnachrichten, Besprechprotokolle. Wir haben auch mit Zeuginnen und Zeugen gesprochen. Wir haben Bilder und Dokumente, die die Verletzungen dieser Frauen dokumentieren. Es ist wirklich nicht so, dass wir aus dem hohlen Bauch eben mal so was aufgeschrieben haben, weil sich das irgendwie gut anhört, sondern es gibt Vorwürfe, über die man rechtlich zulässig Bericht erstatten kann. Dazu gehört natürlich auch, dass man die Gegenseite anhört und das entsprechend berücksichtigt. Das haben wir zumindest in den Fällen, wo wir die Frauen nicht insoweit schützen mussten, dass selbst das nicht möglich war. Aber diese Frauen kommen eben auch nur relativ knapp zur Sprache. Aber in den anderen Fällen haben wir das gemacht. Aber da hatten wir jetzt auch nicht das Gefühl, dass da großes Interesse war, die Gegenversion zu erzählen, sondern da bekamen wir dann Post von Anwälten, die eigentlich pauschal nur abgestritten haben und nicht auf einzelne Vorwürfe eingegangen sind und mit den rechtlichen Konsequenzen von einer unzulässigen Verdachtsberichterstattung gedroht haben. Also es gilt die Unschuldsvermutung, ja natürlich. Es gilt aber auch für die Frauen ein Anspruch darauf, dass man sie mal anhört und dass sie auch das Recht haben, wenn ihnen Unrecht passiert ist, dass man das zur Kenntnis nimmt und dass man als Journalistin sich eben auch damit auseinandersetzt auf eine verantwortungsvolle und medienrechtskonforme Art und Weise.
Und es geht doch auch darum, wenn wir wollen, dass sich da etwas ändert und eventuell solche Geschichten auch anders verlaufen können, dann müssen wir auch dafür sorgen, dass das überhaupt erstmal besprochen werden kann. Und natürlich in einem für alle Seiten fairen Raum. Und da stimme ich komplett mit Gabriela überein. Die Unschuldsvermutung ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Die hat eine riesen Berechtigung und die wurde hier aber auch berücksichtigt.
Sonst wäre keine eurer Texte mehr online. So kann man es doch eigentlich sagen, oder? Also das ist ja unser journalistischer Blick. Wir sehen, wenn so ein Text mit all diesen Details online stehen bleibt, länger, dann ist das wirklich wasserdicht. Denn als Journalist hat man ja fast eher so die – oder man kann zumindest davon ausgehen – ich habe immer so in meinem Kopf eigentlich dann oft die Dinge, die wahrscheinlich noch nicht erzählt werden konnten, weil sie nicht gut genug belegt werden konnten. Weil man gerade bei so langen Recherchen eigentlich weiß, dass ihr da geschrieben habt, das war nicht so, dass ihr da jetzt jeden Textfixe zusammengesucht habt, den ihr hattet, sondern ganz im Gegenteil, ihr hattet wahrscheinlich ein ganzes Konvolut und musstet es dann runterbrechen wirklich auf die Dinge, die eindeutig für euch belegbar sind, wo ihr eben dann eben auch eurer Rolle gerecht werden könnt, eurer Verantwortung, die ihr habt.
Das trifft zu, aber also meine Erfahrung aus dem Investigativ-Journalismus ist tatsächlich so, dass es kommt immer drauf an, ob sich die gegnerische Seite einen Vorteil verspricht, wenn sie jetzt dagegen vorgeht. Also es ist natürlich so, wenn man nach so einem Text, der wirklich harte Vorwürfe gegen ziemlich mächtige und einflussreiche Menschen erhebt, dass da kann man eigentlich erwarten, dass irgendetwas zurückkommt. Wir haben wirklich tatsächlich auch deshalb uns zurückgehalten, irgendwelche Vorwürfe, die jetzt tatsächlich allein auf Aussagen beruhen, sondern wir haben in den meisten Fällen eben noch Dokumente, die die Aussagen stützen und das ist eben sehr, sehr wichtig. Das heißt nicht, dass sie nicht trotzdem dagegen vorgehen können.
Das soll ja auch so sein, das gehört dazu im Rechtsstaat dazu.
Das gehört dazu, wobei natürlich irgendwie, das in meiner Erfahrung, das nimmt schon sehr stark überhand die Presse-Rechtsanwälte, die also extrem aggressiv vorgehen und die zum Teil auch sich durch mehrere Landgerichte klagen. Ich weiß das über einen Fall, wo es auch um einen gewalttätigen Fußballer geht, dessen Anwälte haben, in mehreren Landgerichten versucht, eine einstweilige Verfügung zu erreichen, bis sie schließlich einen gefunden haben, wo es durchgegangen ist. Und da muss man sich tatsächlich auch mal fragen, ob diese Möglichkeit, dass man irgendwo klagen kann, dann noch mal, dann noch mal, bis man alle 16 Bundesländer vielleicht durch hat, ob das wirklich so eine Gerechtigkeit herstellt. Also da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher.
Das ist auch wieder ein Beispiel, wie man mit einem innovativen Ansatz eine Berichterstattung verhindern kann. Und eben genau die Frage ist, ob das jetzt dazu führt, dass da die richtigen Dinge besprochen werden können und die richtigen auch vielleicht nicht.
Man wird immer bei Gewalt gegen Frauenfällen oder geschlechtsspezifischer Gewaltfällen, nennen wir es MeToo oder einfach Gewalt, dann wird man immer wieder das Problem haben, dass man in diesen rechtlich etwas unsicheren Bereich reinkommt, weil letztlich ist es so, dass sich viele Dinge eben nicht hundertprozentig zweifelsfrei und unwiderlegbar belegen lassen. Und die Frage ist natürlich jedes Mal, wie sorgfältig bin ich als Journalistin, mir die Glaubwürdigkeit der Person zuzusichern, wie relevant ist diese Geschichte? Und es geht ja auch nicht gegen irgendwelche privaten Menschen, es geht gegen Leute, die prominente sind, die eine Vorbildfunktion, denen das zumindest zugeschrieben wird und die mit ihrem Image sehr, sehr viel Geld verdienen. Und wenn in der im Privatleben so ein Ausmaß von Gewalt oder Machtbrissbrauch stattfindet, dann bin ich absolut der Meinung, dass das ein öffentliches Interesse hat, weil das, also wie gesagt, es geht auch nicht nur um die einzelnen Spieler, es geht um die Strukturen und es geht um den ganzen Überbau. Und das ist eine Reaktion, die ich von einem Kollegen hatte, der sehr viel zu Kindesmissbrauch durch Pfarrer und Pastoren gemacht hat. Der hat die Recherche gelesen und gesagt, das ist ja wie in der katholischen Kirche. Und das ist tatsächlich der Eindruck, den man haben kann, wenn man sich anguckt, was da alles getan wird, um die mutmaßlichen Täter zu decken.
Und das ist kein Vergleich, den man haben möchte. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es gerade überhaupt noch einen Vergleich gibt, wenn man wie die katholische Kirche sein möchte. Vielleicht so alt wie die katholische Kirche. Vielleicht ist das noch der einzige Vergleich, den man gerade haben möchte. Jetzt haben wir damit schon so ein bisschen gestreift die juristische Reaktion auf eure Veröffentlichung. Und vorher waren wir schon mal ganz kurz beim Thema, aber da würde ich noch gerne mal den Fokus drauf lenken. Wie haben denn die Vereine, die Berater und so weiter reagiert? Also im Großen das System Fußball. Was waren die Reaktionen, die ihr da bekommen habt?
Also es ist überhaupt sehr, sehr schwer, auch da auch nur mal ein Hintergrundgespräch hinzubekommen. Also tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, Gabriela, ob sich bei dir daraufhin jemand aus diesen Strukturen gemeldet hat oder auch nur jetzt mal irgendwie sich konstruktiv damit auseinandergesetzt hat. Da ist großes Schweigen. Und grundsätzlich hat sich da jetzt niemand bei uns gemeldet und gesagt, er oder sie würde gerne in den Diskurs einsteigen. Auch nicht die – ich weiß noch mal – die Diversitätsbeauftragte des DFB zum Beispiel. Vielleicht theoretisch so eine Person, die sich dieses Themas annehmen könnte. Auch da kam jetzt keine Reaktion.
Also wir haben ja verschiedene Vereine angefragt. Wir haben den DFB angefragt und wir haben tatsächlich nur extrem schmallippige Antworten bekommen. Also ich habe jetzt nicht den Eindruck, dass da Gesprächsbedarf besteht. Ich habe eher den Eindruck, dass sich da ganz viele Leute gerade totstellen und hoffen, dass das Thema möglichst schnell wieder aus den Schlagzeilen verschwindet. Es wird aber einen zweiten Teil geben, so schnell wird es nicht gehen.
Das kann ich schon mal versprechen. Sowieso merkt man ja jetzt, dass da offenbar noch sehr, sehr viel mehr mit dranhängt und dass das ja auch die Aufmerksamkeit zeigt, dass es da vielleicht auch eine bestimmte Identifikation oder auch ein Wiedererkennen und so weiter gibt. Was ich daran nicht ganz verstehe, ist jetzt an diesem Ausbleiben der Reaktion oder dass dieser Diskurs dann genau vor den Toren der Fußballwelt haltmacht, sozusagen die öffentliche. Es geht doch jetzt auch gar nicht darum, jetzt Schuldige zu finden. Man könnte sich ja auch so darüber irgendwie verständigen oder damit auseinandersetzen, zu sagen, okay, offenbar haben da bestimmte Fälle stattgefunden. Was können wir denn tun, damit diese Geschichten anders verlaufen und damit auch unsere Branche da – ich will jetzt nicht so weit gehen zu sagen – in eine vorbildliche, aber in so eine vorbildlich-hörer Funktion kommt und damit ja auch wieder – eben, das hat ja so sehr Vorbildskarakter, diese ganze Sportwelt, also auch einfach für so viele Menschen. Und das dann auch mal ernst zu nehmen und zu sagen, okay, wie gehen wir denn mit einer Krise, mit einem Problem in unseren Strukturen um? Und da kann man ja auch konstruktiv mit umgehen. Also es geht uns jetzt nicht darum, dass Vereine sich bei uns melden und sagen, ja, das sind wir übrigens, das ist unser Problem, sondern halt eben zu sagen so, okay, wie sehen unsere Strukturen aus? Gibt es da Angebote? Und wenn nicht, was könnten wir tun? Da könnte man ja auch mal ganz neue Wege gehen.
Also ich meine, man könnte ja schon so ganz einfache Dinge tun, was in zum Beispiel vielen Organisationen und Unternehmen normal ist, dass man Ansprechpartner für Menschen hat, die sexualisierte oder körperliche oder seelische Gewalt erleben, die unabhängig ist. Also in den Fällen, die uns vorliegen, die Frauen sind zum Teil zu dem Berater des Mannes gegangen, um Hilfe zu bekommen bei häuslicher Gewalt. Das ist eigentlich schon eine Absurdität, weil das natürlich – also da kann man auch zum Frosch gehen und sagen, leg mal den Sumpf trocken – es ist der komplett falsche Ansprechpartner. Wir haben da SMS-Wechsel, die wirklich jeglicher Beschreibung spotten, wo dann der Berater antwortet, Fotos bekommt von massiven Hämatomen und Prellungen und schreibt zurück, das sieht nicht schön aus. Ich kann jetzt aber nicht sagen, wer von euch der Gute und der Böse ist. Aber wenn du mal reden willst, komm jederzeit zu mir. Oder die Frau natürlich auch sagt, vielen Dank dafür, ich fahr jetzt ins Krankenhaus.
Und dann aber auch oft schon noch mit einschließt, dass vielleicht jetzt zur Polizei gehen nun ja nicht nötig ist. Das kann man ja sozusagen so in der Familie erklären.
Genau, also in dem Fall gibt der Wechsel auch her, dass irgendjemand Anzeige bei der Polizei erstattet hat. Also möglicherweise, keine Ahnung, Leute, die das mitgekriegt haben. Aber wo dann die Frau auch sich anscheinend zu rechtfertigen hat, wer denn da die Polizei alarmiert hat. Also das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und das zeigt aber auch auf, wie stark diesen Frauen ein Ansprechpartner fehlt, wenn man sich an die Berater des Fußballers wendet. Aber gut, die sind natürlich auch permanent im Leben, dieser Männer präsent und auch in privaten Umfällen. Aber das zeigt halt tatsächlich, wenn es eine Ombudsfrau gebe oder eine Beratungsstelle, die kann ja auch gerne an den Verein angegliedert sein oder an den Verband oder was auch immer. Einfach eine Telefonnummer, die man wählen kann und wo dann irgendwie niedrigschwellige Hilfe möglich ist. Aber das gibt es eben nicht. Und da frage ich mich natürlich schon, was spricht denn dagegen, so etwas zu machen?
Ja und einfach, ich meine, es geht einfach nur darum, einen geschützten Raum herzustellen, in dem nicht der Schutz des Image des Profifußballers an allererster Stelle steht, sondern vielleicht einfach erstmal ein neutraler Raum, in dem man vielleicht eine ganz einfache Hilfe und vielleicht Beratung erstmal bekommt. Und wie gesagt, das ist ja jetzt in anderen Bereichen schon normal und existiert. Das ist ja umsetzbar, ja.
Ja und gleichzeitig finde ich, es gibt da immer eine sehr einfache Argumentation im Sportjournalismus, sowohl auf Seiten von Journalistinnen als auch von Seiten von Beteiligten aus dem Fußballkosmos, die sagen, ja wir machen ja nur Sport, wir konzentrieren uns auf den Sport. Unsere Aufgabe ist ja nur, wir wollen ja nur sicherstellen, dass der gut trainieren kann, dass der beim nächsten Spiel fit ist. Nur deshalb ist das für uns überhaupt relevant, aber ansonsten ja gar nicht. Und ich finde, das kann man halt so eigentlich auch nicht stehen lassen, weil das würde ja, dem würde ja dann widersprechen, warum denn dann zum Beispiel die Partnerinnen von Spielern so wichtig sind bei öffentlichen Anlässen, warum die da dann so gerne genutzt werden, warum die auch, also ich will jetzt nicht den Verein vorwerfen, dass die Freikarten ins Stadion bekommen, soweit möchte ich nicht gehen, aber es ist eben nicht so, dass die Vereine nur von dem Mann profitieren, sondern es gibt eben auch Konstellationen, in denen auch die Partnerin eine wichtige Rolle spielt und gleichzeitig tragen ja auch die Frauen zu einem Image bei der Spieler und auch davon profitieren die Vereine indirekt. Und ich finde das erstaunlich, dass das immer wieder nicht über diese sehr einfachen Argumente hinausgeht. Also das hört man immer wieder und ich vermute, sowas hat man auch schon vor 20 Jahren gesagt. Also gerade dieses Argument auch, wir wollen uns ja auf den Sport konzentrieren, das ist wahrscheinlich so uralt wie der Sportjournalismus selbst schon, aber das ist ja wahnsinnig kurz gedacht und es ist erstaunlich, dass man damit bis heute eigentlich noch sehr häufig wenig Widerspruch hat.
Das ist ein Alibi, also ich halte das für nicht ganz ehrlich, weil im Fußball passiert eine ganze Menge, was wirklich nicht so viel mit Sport zu tun hat. Also nennen wir mal diese ganze Vermarktung, die Werbung, die Sponsoren, all das hat nichts mit dem Sport zu tun und trotzdem ist es irgendwie etwas, worum sich die Vereine dann gerne kümmern. Die Frauen sind ja auch willkommen, solange sie irgendwie hübsche Home-Stories in den Boulevard-Medien machen. Das ist ja etwas, was durchaus encouraged wird. Dass sie da irgendwie zeigen, das ist das schöne Zuhause des Spielers und ich bin seine hübsche Frau und das sind seine süßen Kinder, weil das eben halt der Vermarktung dient. Nur in dem Moment, wo es schwierig wird, heißt es auf einmal irgendwie so, ja wir kümmern uns nur um Fußball und nimm nichts sonst. Also das ist nicht ganz ehrlich.
Und jetzt haben wir ja einen Fall, der wird öffentlich behandelt und auch deshalb haben wir ja zum Beispiel schon über Kasia Lennert und Jerome Boateng gesprochen. Es gibt jetzt gerade ein laufendes Verfahren in München gegen Jerome Boateng, ein Berufungsverfahren. Also es gab schon ein Urteil gegen ihn. Welche Rolle spielt es denn für die Situation von betroffenen Frauen, dass es jetzt diesen einen aktuellen Fall gibt, der verhandelt wird und der es ja auch Journalistinnen und Journalisten ermöglicht, auch über Details zu sprechen?
Das ist tatsächlich eine Sache, die für uns, glaube ich, wichtig war. Denn wir haben hier diesen einen Fall, wo tatsächlich eine Frau einmal Anzeige erstattet hat und wo es ein strafrechtliches Verfahren gibt, inzwischen in zweiter Instanz, was von der Münchner Staatsanwaltschaft extrem ernst genommen wird, was entsprechend auch Bericht erstattet wird, das Interesse an dem Berufungsprozess medial war ziemlich hoch. Also ich hatte das Gefühl, dass unsere Berichterstattung da auch tatsächlich ein Türspalt noch mal weiter geöffnet hat, weil der erste Prozess tatsächlich relativ dünn berichtet wurde. Und jetzt haben die Vorwürfe, die die Ex-Freundin in dem Fall erhebt, doch ziemliches Gehör gefunden. Und tatsächlich ist es so, dass natürlich, also man muss dazu sagen, dass Jérôme Boateng hat immer gesagt, dass er seine Unschuld bestreitet. Jetzt in dem Prozess äußert er sich nicht, aber sein Anwalt hat gleich zu Anfang auch noch mal gesagt, dass er jegliches strafrechtlich relevantes Tun bestreitet. Aber was die Ex-Freundin zu sagen hat, das ist doch jetzt irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit und darüber wird gesprochen. Die Art und Weise, wie mit diesen Vorgängen umgegangen wird, ganz gleich, ob sie sich erhärten lassen oder nicht, aber die Art, wie diese Frau befragt wurde, wie sie immer wieder auch intimste Details preisgeben musste. Es gab diesen Vorfall, wo die Bodyguards ja offenbar eine Zeugin, oder die Zeugin fühlte sich eingeschüchtert von den Bodyguards, weil diese Bodyguards sie ungefragt offenbar gefilmt haben. Alle diese Dinge sind jetzt draußen. Darüber wird geredet und das ist auch tatsächlich sehr gut so.
Und genau dieser Fall ist jetzt einmal ein Beispiel, das alle mit beobachten können, aber einsortiert in dieses Strukturelle, was wir jetzt in der Recherche darstellen konnten. Und ganz vieles lässt sich da auch sehr, sehr gut einsortieren. Und jetzt geht es aber nicht darum zu sagen, der Fall von Jerome Boateng ist in sich beispielhaft für vieles. Aber das, was rundherum die Mechanismen, die greifen, die Strukturen, die bedient werden, dieses Machtungleichgewicht, all das lässt sich daran sehr, sehr gut erkennen. Und es ist natürlich jetzt auch nochmal spannend, das Ganze zu betrachten, wenn dieses Berufungsverfahren dann abgeschlossen ist, denke ich, und dann nochmal zu diskutieren, wie die Resonanz ist, wie sich das alles abgespielt hat und was wir daraus für Schlüsse, auch für diesen strukturellen Machtmissbrauch ziehen können.
Richtig. Also was uns, glaube ich, wichtig ist, wir wollen jetzt nicht uns auf Boateng konzentrieren. Boateng ist ein Fußballer, gegen den gleich mehrere Frauen Vorwürfe erhoben haben. Einmal Kascha Lehnhardt und dann die Frau, die jetzt im Berufungsprozess auch wieder aufgesagt hat. Und die Vorwürfe stehen einfach im Raum. Es gibt dazu Ermittlungsverfahren und die kann man jetzt einfach nicht mehr wegdiskutieren. Letztlich aber geht es uns überhaupt nicht um die Person Jerome Boateng, weil es gibt mehrere andere Fußballer, wo teilweise Anzeigen erstattet wurden, teilweise nicht, die jetzt aber nicht in der Öffentlichkeit sind bisher, die aber auf eine ganz ähnliche Art und Weise operiert haben und wo ganz ähnliche Strategien auch zum Tragen kamen.
Und trotzdem ist es halt eben jetzt extrem interessant zu sehen, wie, also ich meine zum Beispiel diese Situation, in der die Bodyguards von Jerome Boateng es für eine gute Idee halten, im Kontext einer Gerichtsverhandlung eine relevante Zeugin zu filmen, die sich dann dadurch unter Druck gesetzt fühlt. Das ist ja, das zeigt für mich dieses Selbstverständnis und auch dieser, ja, also das Selbstvorgericht. Der Eindruck da ist, dass andere Regeln für einen gelten, und man so ein bisschen eventuell auch sich unantastbar fühlt und so eine Konsequenzlosigkeit für selbstverständlich nimmt. Und dann, ja, also dass die einfach diese, ja, so eine Art rechtsfreier Raum gefühlt entsteht um jemanden und das vor Gericht. Das ist schon interessant auch als Fallhöhe für das, was wir beschrieben haben vorher als strukturelles Problem, dass sich allerdings eben nicht nur auf Jerome Boateng bezieht, sondern auch viele andere.
Das war eine interessante Inszenierung. Dieser Mann, dieser Fußballer, der reinkommt, begleitet von drei Bodyguards und ich glaube drei oder vier Anwälten, wo die Ex-Freundin auf der anderen Daseite sitzt mit ihrer einen Anwältin, das schafft gleich vor Gericht so einen Eindruck von, also Waffengleichheit ist das nicht. Boateng hat nicht ausgesagt, er saß die ganze Zeit schweigend da und hat seine Anwälte für ihn reden lassen. Und die Frau musste sich, auf Deutsch gesagt, komplett loslegen. Also mit allem, was ihr passiert ist, mit allem, was auch die Beziehung zu ihrem Ex-Freund Boateng angeht, bis hin zu der Frage, wann sie ihre Periode hatte und wann sie das letzte Mal Geschlechtsverkehr mit ihm hatte, vor diesem ganzen versammelten Gericht. Und das ist tatsächlich auch ein Umgang mit Frauen, die Gewalt erlebt haben oder entsprechende Vorwürfe erheben, wo ich glaube, dass unser Rechtssystem sich dringend auch ändern muss.
Absolut. Und das Ganze muss man sich ja auch mal vorstellen, das was Gabriela hier gerade beschrieben hat, also diese wirklich das in peinlichste Details gehende Befragung, in der es dann auch natürlich von den Anwälten von Jerome Boat hängt darum, gegen ihre Glaubwürdigkeit in Frage zu stellen, sie zu diskreditieren, also um ihn zu entlasten. Das alles hat sich ja in der Öffentlichkeit abgespielt. Also da sind ja Medien waren ja eben zugelassen. Und das ist ja auch eine Situation, die man sich jetzt einfach mal auf einer menschlichen Ebene vorstellen muss. Und ja, auch da gilt wieder die Unschuldsvermutung. Aber es steht auch im Raum, dass es sich eben so abgespielt hat. Und wenn man das auch mal mit einbezieht, dass da jemand sitzt, der potentiell wirklich Traumatisches erlebt hat, der dann sich stundenlang so einer Situation aussetzen muss, in aller Öffentlichkeit darüber dann hinterher berichtet werden muss, das ist eigentlich auch noch mal ein Missstand für sich, wo man sich auch noch mal als Gesellschaft fragen muss, ob das eigentlich ein Vorgehen ist, was angemessen ist in so einer Konstellation.
Also ich sehe schon, wir werden noch mal sprechen müssen, sowohl über den Fall Boateng, der dann ja auch ein rechtsgültiges Urteil haben wird, irgendwann noch läuft da gerade die Berufungsverhandlung und dann der von euch angekündigte Teil 2 zu eurer Recherche. Das ist ein ganz komisches Gefühl. Man weiß ja gar nicht, ob man sich über so etwas freuen kann. Wahrscheinlich dann schon, weil ja etwas, was schon passiert ist, dann aufgedeckt wird und hoffentlich zu einer Verbesserung führt. Das ist natürlich die Hoffnung, die wir alle drei haben. Ich danke euch sehr für eure Zeit. Ihr seid sehr gefragte Menschen, ihr habt sehr viel zu tun. Ich weiß es wirklich zu schätzen, dass ihr euch so viel Zeit genommen habt. Herzlichen Dank an Gabriela Keller vom Correctiv als Add-Gabriela Keller auch auf Twitter. Danke dir, Gabriela, dass du hier im Rasenfunk warst. Und danke an Maike Backhaus, freie Journalistin, als Add-Maike Backhaus auch bald auf Twitter. So richtig aktiv. Danke dir, liebe Maike.
Ganz vielen Dank, dass wir hier das ganze Thema so gut besprechen konnten.
Jederzeit wieder. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke ich vor eurer Aufmerksamkeit. Noch einmal der Hinweis, wenn ihr mit diesem Thema Probleme habt oder betroffen seid. Es sind alle Informationen in den Shownotes verlinkt. Ich freue mich auf Feedback zu dieser Sendung unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und im sozialen Netzwerk eurer Wahl. Wir sind eigentlich überall vertreten. Und in diesem Sinne bleibt gesund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, bleibt dem Rasenfunk treu. Und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk-Tribünengespräch. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.